new york republican congressman john
catgo sits on the homeland security
ranking member there congressman we're
told that this isn't over as bill was
touching on here that the cbb um didn't
go far enough and this investigation
didn't reach far enough and that some
individual members even though um you
know that
as a group they've been exonerated could
be targeted for further punishment what
do you think
yeah neil this is a colossal reach from
the get-go and you know i was a federal
organized crime prosecutor for 20 years
in fact i worked on the border i worked
with these people side by side and they
risked their lives every day and they
followed the orders they were placed
into the situation because of this
administration having an open border
policy they weren't even trained in
crowd control on horseback yet they told
them to go there then they were
exonerated and yet from the beginning
they've been convicted in the court of
public opinion by the president and the
leadership at homeland security and they
had to do something to justify the fact
that uh they were found that they that
innocent of of the charges of strapping
and whipping people they weren't so now
they they had they concoct this 500-page
report to trash these people and
uh at this point i'm not sure any border
patrol agent would ever do anything to
try and stop the flow of people coming
across the border because if they do
things like this happen to them it's
terrible situation we're showing the
border right now and it's hardly back to
normal or whatever normal is so
obviously such incidents are continuing
not the horse uh incidents here but the
you know
more trying to to break through that
border and now we're told that it's
possible that uh cpb can no longer uh
you know use horses in the pursuit of
migrants in an area uh were saved in the
four-wheel drive vehicles um even they
have a tough time through some of this
geography and i'm i'm wondering then
what
no neil it is all they're doing is
peeling back more and more the ability
of the customs of border protection to
do their job and it's demoralizing to
them and it's more dangerous to them and
you're right a lot of these places in
the brush the only thing that really
works is horses and by the way they're
saving lives every day which no one
knows about you're saving tons of lives
of people that are stranded out in the
middle of the desert and they do it
because they're on horseback patrolling
and now they're going to peel that back
this this agency in this administration
has created an epic disaster at the
border and not only are they creating a
disaster now they're going after their
own which is to me just reprehensible
law enforcement or lack thereof you know
what's wild about it whatever regardless
of your views of the subject congress
and we are going
after the people who are trying to
protect the border then we are
addressing the the havoc at the border
it just seems kind of ass backwards
absolutely neil and think about this
they started this whole crisis with the
just stroke of a pen on january 20th of
last year when biden wrote back and met
many policies and signaled that the
border was basically open they said so
because they thought it was just the
northern triangle folks coming across
and people from mexico well that's just
not true bad guys across the world are
exploiting the southern border we've had
50 people on the terra watch list that
have been seized which stands the reason
at least that many have come through
this year which is multiple times more
than ever before you've got people from
160 different countries being caught at
the border and you know the godways are
skyrocketing numbers are skyrocketing
and and what are they doing they're
going after their own i think this is
disgraceful i really do and i've been in
law enforcement in an awful long time
yeah that perspective is valuable
congressman john catkal the new york
republican sits on the house homeland
security committee we'll be getting
updates on this but again for a lot of
people just looking at like wow
we're pursuing the wrong folks we'll be
on top of that stay on top of that
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight